[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages it the next half hour then
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the editor of the Jewish Chronicle
Jake Wallace Simons and the broadcaster
and former government Minister Anna
supri happy New Year and great to see
both of you front pages though let's
crack on with those shall we and uh the
I first of all uh Tory voters blaming
the government for the NHS crisis uh
poll shows that's the front of the eye
which says 73 percent of conservatives
think the party has mismanaged the
Health Service over the last 10 years
meanwhile the mayor quotes the head of
the Royal College of emergency
medicine's warning that they could be
500 patient deaths a week this winter as
the care crisis deepens that warning
also making the front page of the Daily
Express
the times two makes it the main front
page story a e delays killing up to 500
patients every week
the guardian meanwhile says that more
prolonged strikes in the NHS are on the
way because Health unions Fair ministers
are planning to cap pay Rises to just
two percent next year
with record migrant numbers crossing the
channel more rail strikes and of course
the NHS crisis it all adds up says the
mail to a triple New Year headache for
prime minister Rishi sunak
the telegraph reports that Mr sunac has
shelved plans for an overhaul of the
child care system aimed at saving
parents money and helping them get back
to work the plan originally came from
his predecessor Liz truss and with not
long to go now before Prince Harry's
book spare is published the sun says its
Revelations will mean the gloves finally
come off in the war of words with his
brother Prince William
and finally barking mad that's how the
star headlines its story that local
councils are spending Millions planting
new trees which then die because the job
hasn't been done properly
don't forget scan that QR code and you
can see the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you listen to our
guests so let's head then to Jake and to
Anna and uh welcome to the new year at
Rishi sunak and Anna what a set of
headlines for the for the prime minister
yeah this is really concerning um if if
they don't get as they should the
appalling crisis in our NHS then that
front page of the eye should really hit
home because it says 73 of conservative
voters voters which is different to
members conservative voters blame the
government for mismanaging the NHS in
the last 10 years that is a very serious
figure and that should certainly make
Rishi sunak and Steve Barkley get this
crisis under control and get a grip the
first thing they can do is to meet the
nurses unions the other unions in the
NHS all the president's chairs of the
royal colleges and look at the staff and
how they are going to settle the strikes
and how they're going to make sure they
put into measures
put into enforced measures to retain and
then recruit people to the front line
because Frontline workers are exhausted
and they are utterly demoralized and
that must be the priority
well let's take a look inside the the
mirror Jake as well NHS in crisis killer
delays uh they call it
um flu season uh wreaking havoc to a
creaking NHS is part of the uh the
headline shock staff to live dickensian
conditions certainly people have told us
that oh I think I've lost Jake and I'm
going to stick with you if you don't
mind anyway
um we'll get Jake back
oh your lights have gone off okay well I
might just talk to you anywhere but
anyway
um while we look at this newspaper but
Jake uh go back to you um the quotes
we've had today from Dr Adrian Boyle
president of the Royal College of
emergency medicine
um that 300 to 500 people are dying each
week as a consequence to these delays
and also we spoke to Dr Tim cookley you
look very interesting I have to say uh
president of the society for acute
medicine
um said this is worse than the peak of
the NHS we'll cover a newspaper over you
because uh you're in Black anyway carry
on Jake
ah
I think we have lost him Anna go on then
if you don't mind answering that
question I apologize
let's hope we get him back but in the
meantime I mean this is as we as we know
there's your reporting as well this is a
very serious crisis Dr Adrian Boyle
who's the uh present the Royal College
of emergency medicine says that up to
500 people a week are dying because of
the crisis in in a in particular and yes
of course flu is part of it but you know
it's right that we are I think most most
families have experienced some of these
disgusting bugs that seem to be going
around this year in a way that they
haven't before and know that that's to
do with what that is sort of a hangover
from covid but most importantly is that
we should expect an NHS that can have
the capacity to deal with these sorts of
crises which are not unpredictable
especially at this time of the year and
so this is this is it's not it's not
that the NHS is on its knees it's
actually on its face
and the Urgent action now has to be
taken by the government in the way that
I describe but there are other measures
of course that they must do as well
because it's real human beings there's a
suffering
um and it's it's it is the worst that's
what I'm getting from family and friends
who work in the NHS this is the worst
crisis that it has ever experienced yeah
and the Dell Express again another of
those newspapers 500 patients dying a
week due to delays when people read that
and I include in that people in cabinet
the pressure will only grow on the
government as you say sort out the NHS
nurses strike but also you know
fundamentally
um I don't know take more care of their
staff as you say are exhausted and
they're short-staffed that that issue
causes deeper exhaustion for people
doesn't it
it does and morale is absolutely as as
bad as you might imagine and these are
extraordinary people who work incredibly
hard that always go the extra mile and
they're getting to Absolute breaking
point so if we can if we can do the
right thing by those front line workers
that will go a long way to helping to
fix this immediate crisis because at the
moment it is so bad that people are just
saying I really I can't cope with this
anymore I'm going to leave so we've got
a real problem with retention and we
know we've got a problem with
recruitment as well
one of the things I think we need to do
is look at those EU lines so we get
people back into our NHS who were here
because of our membership to the
European Union many of whom have gone
home sorry did you yeah we got Jake back
yet no do you know what there's a power
cut on his street which builds into that
New Year it's all falling apart feeling
that everyone seems to have at the
minute but we're hoping well I don't
know when are we going to fix that I
mean we're not fixing that oh it's not
our problem he can't even turn the
computer back on and off again anyway
um so at the moment you're you're a
one-woman show
um but I'm going to get to the guys
I know well we could monitor the
progress of his power card as one of
those camera things shouldn't we anyway
but anyway
um now the guardian is talking about the
fact that NHS strikes far from being
solved could continue for uh months
ahead because they say the suggestion is
that ministers have asked the NHS pay
review body to cap the increase in
Frontline health workers pay to just two
percent that's for 23 to 24. we've all
been waiting for the next pay with your
body as possibly a solution to this
crisis but not I suppose Anna if the
request has come through for it to be
capped
no exactly and to me I mean this is this
is an appalling headline for government
um and this will the fury won't just be
amongst the British public but it will
also I think be amongst conservative
backbenchers who are looking at their
Futures they are worried that they're
not going to many of them keep their
seats to the next election and things
like that headline of the Guardian will
really concern them about their own
Futures I mean it should concern them
anyway of course but you know just being
realistic about how a lot of members of
parliament or government mentors will be
thinking but the the real the really
concerning thing is that it doesn't seem
like anybody in government has any idea
about how you negotiate with unions they
just don't seem to have that that
experience and to Steve Barkley who I'm
not saying is incompetent by any means
he he is competent but he just seems
utterly clueless to to have meetings
with leaders of the nurses at Royal
College and other unions but refuse to
talk about hey where they're taking
strike action for the very first time
really is grossly irresponsible on his
behalf and it's like we need those big
grown-ups in government to sit down and
get this sorted and I actually think the
British the British people would pay
extra in taxation
if it's if they thought it was going to
make the differences which it would make
to our NHS which is in this appalling
State and as I say
stop I mean part of the thing that Liz
truss pointed out is that that we are a
very heavily taxed Nation right now and
where do you stop because the the drain
effectively of the NHS continues each
year because effectively we're living
longer but I just want to bring in the
Daily Mail as well which brings in all
the other issues on the table for uh
Rishi sunak some of which he discussed
in the Sunday Express you know an
article he wrote today but included in
the 500 dying a week due to NHS delays
the 45 000 Channel migrants now
confirmed the figure out today and the
union is preparing for this double
walkout week of rail chaos I know a
number of people already thinking of
working from home we're straight back
into strike action aren't we Anna
yeah and this is I don't often say the
Daily Mail is right but that headline's
absolutely right this is his big
headache he's got three big issues there
and if he stands any chance at all he's
got he's gonna have to grip those three
issues two of which come back to this
point which I was saying about
getting somebody there with the
experience of how you negotiate reunions
because people will you know people are
going to get really fed up with whether
it's the rail whether it's what's
happening in the NHS and they will as
we've seen in that I report blame
government so it's absolutely beholdant
on government to get people together if
necessary bang heads together with the
NHS and make the extra money available
but it it is up to them to do that as
for the boats crisis
I personally don't think that sending
people off to Rwanda is the solution I
think it's deeply ironic that we left
the European Union to take control over
our borders actually we have less
control over our borders but in human
terms 45 000 people taking that terrible
perilous Journey uh and it's something
again the government has got to grip and
the concern is it doesn't seem to be
able to do that
well we will come back after a break see
if Jake's back my last pack oh is he
there my last pack up was 10 hours just
so you all know anyway lots more still
to come uh including barking mad
thousands of new trees are dying because
of bad Council planting that story and
plenty more in just a moment
foreign
[Music]
watching The Press preview by some small
miracle we have jquala Simons editor of
the Jewish comical and Anna subri
broadcaster and former government
Minister who's been holding the fort
Jake for you have to say but it's lovely
to see you back again and let's go to
the Telegraph and a Liz truss
prospective policy uh being ditched the
paper suggests by Rishi sunak
that's right so Liz truss's proposal was
to radically overhaul the child care
provision uh in England in Britain
um and it had two parts to it one was to
increase the level of free provision by
20 hours a week and the other was to
lift the cap on the not on the ratio of
children to child care provider meaning
that more children could basically be
looked after by a small number of carers
and these two measures would have made a
very big difference uh to uh voters
particularly in Liberal Democrats in
seats where the tourists are competing
against liberal Democrats with lots of
you know mothers who are seeking to work
and parents they're seeking to work and
so forth
um make a big difference to them in in
terms of their household budget at this
time obviously of primary concern to
everybody but also would have helped the
Tories
um overall to appeal to those voters and
put them in a better position with the
next election coming up and Richardson
shelved those measures entirely it seems
and has yet to put forward him his own
alternative proposals now it would seem
quite obvious why he would want to
abandon the idea of 20 further hours of
free child care a week to parents I mean
that seemed to be part of this great
unfunded Bonanza of giveaways that Liz
truss put in place immediately and that
then came a proper uh shortly afterwards
but it's difficult to see why Richard
zunak is also rescinding her pledge to
drop the child care ratio because that
would have been a great way of easing
the system uh making more child care
provision available to people more
cheaply without costing the treasury
money okay and I'm going to move on I
know you're itching to talk about that
but just got one minute left and we'll
go to the The Daily Star which is
barking mad that actually
um it looks like a large number of
councils have started planting trees in
a rush job um being given 11 million
pounds of taxpayers cash and they die
because they simply don't have the
resources to look after these fledgling
trees
yes this is really rather concerning I
mean you always have to be careful with
daily stars to whether that wonderful
headline actually when you read the
substance is made out but yeah you can
imagine this can't you that they've
planted all these trees but they haven't
as as they say they haven't got the
resources they need to make sure that
they actually survive I don't know
whether the extreme heat that we have
this summer played any part in it but it
is concerning because we need to keep on
planting trees yes I'm sure it did in
fact um Anna Jake lovely to see both
thank you both very much